this is a genuine Crossroads they
genuine they generally come along only
once in a lifetime uh the span of a of a
human life is about how often they do
come along I always knew they were
coming along and especially in the case
of the Jews when I was a little kid I
grew up Jewish I'm a Christian now but I
grew up Jewish and I'm Jewish by race
and I used to say we are holiday Jews
because the Holocaust had awakened
people to the depth and evil of of
anti-Semitism and Jew hatred it's a very
specific thing and I used to say where
it's a holiday because eventually
they'll forget eventually a new
generation will come
along one of the biggest mistakes that
we let happen in the narrative as it's
now called is to let people say that the
Holocaust was about bigotry or that it
was about otherness or that it was about
nationalism it was about specifically
Jew
hatred I'm Dave ruin and joining me
today is the host of the Andrew claven
show and author of the new book The
House of Love and Death a Cameron winter
mystery Andrew claven my old friend
welcome back to the Reuben report good
to see you Dave Andrew I am now
officially confused have you written
more books or been on the Reuben report
more times which one I think it's kind
of goes up and down you know it's like
one week is one thing when the next week
it's another thing but it's it is a it's
a race I always ask you how many books
you've written and you're never quite
sure do you still not know I I don't
know but it's it's over 30 I mean I've
written a lot of books I mean I've been
alive for 125
years it's only when you parse it out
it's not that that oh right so that's
yeah all right that by years I guess
that's not a terrible no you are you are
quite a prolific writer on top of
talking about the news and everything
else you're doing with the daily wire uh
are you or before we're going to do a
little bit of current events and we're
going to talk about the book obviously
and I want to talk more broadly also
about publishing and what's going on in
that world and everything else uh but do
you ever run out of ideas or are you
like already in your head working on the
next thing I'm I'm usually working on
the next thing I mean people people who
say to me I want to be a writer but I
don't have any ideas I think well then
you're not a writer that's that's why
you become a writer because you have
these things you want to say you have
these stories you have to tell it's it's
the kind of profession where you
shouldn't do it unless you absolutely
have to do it because it's tough It's a
tough profession to to get by and I
consider myself I I think there are more
people who play Major League Baseball at
this given moment than there are people
like me who make a living writing
fiction so it's not something you do for
fun I would imagine though fiction must
sell better than nonfiction is that
that's what I would think Am I Wrong
actually as I was saying it maybe yeah
it's it's not true first of all think
about promoting it you know like people
tune in to shows like ours because they
want to talk about the news they want to
talk about non-fiction if you come on
with a uh espec and this is especially
true of conservatives I'm sad to say
conservatives and men that they listen
they say well it's the story is not true
so why do I want to hear it you know I
want to hear about you know Herbert
Hoover or something like that and uh you
know the purposes of art are mysterious
to Americans Europeans understand it
better it is a way of expanding your
life expanding your soul expanding your
experience of the world but you have to
really think about it before you
understand that and so it's really hard
to go on a news-oriented show and say
look if you want to know the world
better you should read fiction
it's a hard s right I guess what I was
trying to say is I wish more people read
fiction because good fiction good
fiction is actually probably how you get
more to the truth than good non-fiction
in some weird Jordan Peters Andes sense
right it it's exactly right and Jordan
has a lot to say about it I mean there's
something about narrative and
storytelling art in general I would say
that gives you the entire Human
Experience and then when you go back to
real life you have a broader perspective
and a deeper perspective Ive and a more
Humane perspective art is an incredibly
uh an incredible tool for increasing
your Insight in humanity all right well
let's uh bring this back to the world of
non-fiction for just a couple minutes
and talk about everything going on in
the world because the this last two
months at this point have been very very
bizarre I I sense that almost everyone
across the globe that is at least
remotely plugged into what's happening
in the world is sensing that the the old
world is not coming back you could say
that about covid about a bunch of things
that about the original uh appearance of
trump politically but that this this
Israel October 7th event was so horrific
and now subsequently what we're seeing
on the streets in Europe in Canada here
in America and elsewhere now this
stabbing in Ireland this election in
Argentina the protests in Spain this now
election in in um in Holland there is
something happening to the world right
now um since you have a couple years on
me I only mention that cuz you mentioned
it up top have you seen this story
before of these moments where the world
starts going in one direction or another
direction or maybe coming back I haven't
seen it I haven't seen it like this this
is a genuine Crossroads they genuine
they generally come along only once in a
lifetime uh the span of a of a human
life is about how often they do come
along I always knew they were coming
along and especially in the case the
Jews when I was a little kid I grew up
Jewish I'm a Christian now but I grew up
Jewish and I'm Jewish by race and I used
to say we are holiday Jews because the
Holocaust had awakened people to the
depth and evil of of anti-Semitism and
Jew hatred it's a very specific thing
and I used to say where it's a holiday
because eventually they'll forget
eventually a new generation will come
along one of the biggest mistakes that
we let happen in the narrative as it's
now called is to let people say that the
Holocaust was about bigotry or that it
was about otherness or that it was about
nationalism it was about specifically
Jew hatred Jew hatred is a unique thing
it doesn't expand other things and of
course I'm against all bigotry all
racial bigotry certainly but but Jew
hatred is special because the Jews hold
a special place in the history of the
world they're the authors of the Bible
and you you know you don't have to
believe in God to understand that this
is true people hate God God expects
something of them that they don't want
to give he expects something better of
them than they know they are he shines a
light on their shame they have for the
Brokenness of their uh inner selves and
they want to erase it by they think that
by erasing the Jews they'll erase the
people who wrote the book on God and so
in these moments when evil arises Jew
hatred Rises with it and it's shocking
to see and it's shocking to see it's
disgusting to see I mean the things that
Hamas did are obviously disgusting but
it's disgusting to see students at
Harvard uh at at other top universities
and other not top universities coming
out and supporting that without the
professors thinking to themselves oh my
god what have I done not one Professor
has come out and said I taught these
kids wrong some I did something terribly
wrong some of them probably privately
think it or maybe can't believe that
they had something to do with this but I
guess probably a whole bunch of them are
happy with the indoctrination yes that's
right and and they don't see I mean
ideology I mean S niton talks about this
a lot ideology can blind you to the evil
that you're doing and make you think
that the evil is good all of us in our
hearts we have this conscience this
god-given conscience We Do Spot things
little things like the slaughtering of
babies and the raping of women we think
ah yes that's evil but an ideology can
convince you that that's somehow
Justified and that is the ideology
that's being taught on our campuses and
the Democrat Party is in a hilariously
Wicked Darkly hilarious uh state where
their young people are basically saying
to Joe Biden you know you don't hate the
Jews enough and Biden is scrambling to
bring out more hatred because he's
living in another
generation what would be the story that
we should be telling that would get us
out of this I don't mean just the Jews
but like the west and you know I was in
London a couple weeks ago at Jordan
Peterson's AR conference and that was
what the purpose of the entire
conference was what are the better
stories that the West has we've just
completely forgotten how to tell our
story and whether you like it or not the
the hnic that are chanting on the
streets their story is pretty freaking
clear we're here for world domination
we're going to kill you and by the way
we got a this trans idiot is going to
help me do it and I'll behead him when
I'm done with you guys that's right yeah
my my response to that is is very
unpopular uh it is the one thing that
nobody wants to admit we're going to
have to start talking about God and
we're going to have to start you know
there there is a God space in every
person I think it was Pascal who said
there's a god-shaped hole in every human
being and there's you know we went from
the new atheism they're now talking
about the new agnosticism Jordan
Peterson and I have gone back and forth
on this you know it's time to come out
and say yes I don't know there's a God
but yes I do have faith and I will act
as if there is a God and that will show
that will either just as when you act as
if there's gravity your life goes better
you can't see gravity but if you act as
if it's there your life is going to go
better the same thing happens with God
you you see him when you believe in him
and in fact your life goes better we
can't make the arguments we have to make
without saying that we are created
creatures this this comes up in
transgenderism very obviously you hear
people on the right saying it's not
natural or it can't be done well one day
it'll be done and who cares if it's
natural air conditioning isn't natural
and I love it you know that's that's not
the answer the answer is we are created
in a certain way and it's good it is a
good thing you were given you were given
some a gift and given with that gift
comes responsibilities and so when we
start talking rationally uh about the
actual state of human Affairs will be
able to argue back this basic
libertarian idea that somehow it's good
for you to be free why is it good what's
good about it people do terrible things
when they're free and yet what a man is
what a human being is is someone who
should be free and you can't make that
argument without saying cre so when when
is when then is my question to you when
is when when will we do this because I
know that there are some people
obviously online I think amongst them
that are trying to have these
conversations trying to wake people up
trying not to do all of the awful things
that have led us here but our entire
cultural apparatus the mainstream media
the New York Times every they're still
lying about absolutely everything
virtually all of our politicians are
lying about absolutely everything so so
when is when or or what gets us to when
well you know I I'm not as desp sparing
as all that from just because of the
fear being exhibited by the left the
fact that Elon musk developed one social
media company that allows you know
right-wing people to express opinions
right-wing people of Goodwill he's not
allowing all kinds of hatred he's just
allowing rightwing people of Goodwill to
say why we are the way we are and what
we believe in and think of this this is
a guy who 10 minutes ago was a hero of
the left for his electric cars and now
he's being investigated like his shoe
sizes are being investigated by the
federal government and they're doing
everything they can to boycott him and
bring him down if they had control of
narrative that they want to have and
that it sometimes appears that they have
they wouldn't be working so hard and in
such a panicked manner to shut us down
and I don't think they can do it any
more than the Catholics could shut down
the printing press when the Reformation
started I think this information
revolution is on our side because we're
telling the truth and I think and we're
right about so many things that
eventually they're just going to have to
break and say we're going to live with
with these two ideas and let the best
one win and then the game is ours
are you saying much like Jeff Goldblum
said in Jurassic Park that life finds a
way we're going to be okay one way or
another yeah life does find a way and
freedom finds a way and the problem is
that freedom is harder because people
don't want to be free they want to be
given stuff they want to make they want
to be safe they want to have food they
want to make sure they're not going to
fall through the cracks so freedom is
frightening but but life tends toward
Freedom it tends toward the moral it
tends toward the good nobody really
thinks that a man can become a woman
nobody really thinks that uh raping and
and murdering is a good thing they have
to be talked into that and so you come
back to the natural self the created
self and then you have to start asking
yourself questions as I did when I was
late in my 40s I start to say well if
it's true if it's true that raping
someone to death and then desecrating
her body while crowds cheer is a bad
thing what makes it bad who says it's
bad where does this Badness and goodness
where do these ideas of Badness and
goodness come from when you start asking
asking those basic questions you got to
come home and and once you come home I
think the entire Enlightenment starts
again the question you know Mark Stein
used to say this you know if it can't
continue it will stop but it matters
whether you stop at the top of the cliff
or after you've gone over the edge right
and that does seem to be the problem
that the enlightenment Liberals are all
having right now that you know it all
kind of worked when things were good and
we had strong men in strong societies
but when things start
crumbling then your tolerance is
starting to see
a little th let me just ask you one
other thing that you mentioned and then
we talk a bit about the book um because
you were born Jewish grew up Christian
we we've discussed this on a couple
different shows over time but in light
of the last two months how do you I
don't know if reconcile is the right
word but but knowing you come from the
people that this horrific thing happened
to your your belief system now is sort
of part two of that belief system uh yet
you obviously have an affinity for the
culture and all that like how do you
piece all this together just personally
right now now well fortunately
spiritually I suppose yeah I never made
the mistake of saying I I'm now no
longer a Jew I always knew that when the
hatred arose I would not be exempt so I
was
never they still going to come for you
you tough Christian you I I also
disagree with a an
old theory of Christianity which is
sometimes called replacement you know
theology or secessionism you know where
they say that yes the Jews were the
favored people of God that chose people
have gotten now we have replaced them I
believe that we have been added on that
the Christians have been added on to
this Jewish god I was talking about
visiting my sister out in California and
she's a friend of Barry Weiss and Barry
I don't know if you know Barry but she
likes she likes to nip at you I love her
to death but she loves to nip at you and
she was saying to me well how do you how
do you reconcile like if if we don't
believe in Jesus we're going to hell and
I said you know my actual opinion not
lying to you is as a Jew you're driving
a Model T forward and you could be
driving a Tesla but a Model T Ford is a
good car it'll get you there you know
and that's that is kind of the way I I
feel about it you know I think that that
uh God chose the Jews to reintroduce
himself into the world and in doing that
he shaped their hearts in a certain way
and at some point that became a thing
that could be given to the rest of the
world through Jesus and that's that's
the way I see it so I've been kind of um
saved from getting into stupid you know
life's not a game show it's not like
it's not like you guess the right name
of God and you go to heaven bing bing
bing you know it's like you have to live
you have to find that thing in yourself
that loves that is patient that is kind
and then you're on your right the right
path and yes do I think that Christ is
the best way to do that yes I do but I
do think that people who don't know that
name uh can find that place in their
hearts where he lives so I'm not really
cons concerned about it for the record I
am a Jew although I do have a model X so
yeah now you're going to hell anyway
that's just
just it's a it's a personal thing with
you this has nothing to do with
the talk to me about Cameron winter
Cameron winter has been now in how many
books you must at least know that this
yes I do know that this is the third
book with Cameron winter and just this
very day I sent in the manuscript for
the fourth book uh and the fifth one is
under contract so the series is
continuing it's been they've all been
bestsellers so it's been great and um
and you know the thing is everything
that we were just talking about not
maybe not the religious parts of it well
even the religious parts of I wanted to
put this guy who is trying who was a bad
guy in his day but is now trying to
become a good guy I wanted to put him
into a society like ours which is
reaching a crisis point and we were
talking about this before I think these
are issues that you can explore better
in art than you can just ranting and
just theorizing and and even you know
just using statistics when you put a man
who the audience can identify with and
can understand what he's looking for
when you put him in a situation that's
like our situation you can see it more
deeply and so these are stories about a
guy moving through an America that is at
crisis point and even maybe a bit beyond
where we are he's moving through in
America it takes place now but it's just
a little bit ahead of now and um and
he's a guy who like in in the house of
Love and Death he's a guy who goes into
enclaves of surviving civilizations so
this is a little gated community he goes
into where a family has been wiped out
and he starts to realize how the
corruption of the world around it is
seeping in to any place where you try to
escape and that's what the books are
about and they're about a man trying to
make sense of the world and trying to
find the truth in a world like that so
you know it's funny I I haven't read the
book yet I am going to read it but I was
reading the synopsis and what you just
described right there I was thinking oh
man that's my fear for Florida that we
have our little Community here our
little Safe Community here but you can't
fully inocular inoculate yourself from
the rest of the world yeah and and my
argument is that the individual search
for meaning for Justice For Truth these
are the things that bring a society back
it you know it's not the next election
it's never going to be one thing or
another it's always going to be
individuals coming forward uh and and
saying wait a minute we are on the wrong
track I'm going to live in a diff on a
different track even if they throw me to
the Lions because this is the truth this
is the meaning of my life I was so um
elevated by the news that Ian hery Al a
woman I greatly admire I think you you
have expressed we're we're good friends
she's I adore her she's she's an angel
she actually is an angel she is one of
the most noble people I think in our
public life and after years of being one
of the new atheists she basically uh
found Christ in a in a similar way to
the way I did which was basically saying
you know I I now believe there's a God
but what's he like and then you suddenly
realize you're rewriting the gospels and
you think like well you this be a lot
easier if I just take what's already on
the table and and I think that that is
something I've been predicting for years
that a new um a new birth of Faith was
going to come down not from the streets
not from the Street Preachers not from
the tents was going to come down from
the elite because they realize that
they're walking in emptiness and on a in
a wasteland and I think that that's what
happened to TS Elliott in his time he
knew he was in a wasteland and he found
faith and I think it's going to happen
again because it's the only thing that
makes sense I you know I keep making
this argument and I know some people
when I when I was an atheist or even an
agnostic and you said the word Jesus or
even God it felt to me like you were
dropping a caterpillar down the back of
my neck i' be don't no don't talk about
that but once you see it you can't unsee
it and I think when people like Ian hery
Lee are seeing it uh then a lot of
people are going to start to see it as
well and I've been predicting this as I
say for over a decade I think it's
coming now yeah well I suppose when you
see a secular world that as you
reference tells you boys or girls and
that rape is good that people start
going okay maybe maybe there's some old
book that might be a I mean that really
is I I've thought that a lot over the
last couple of months you know and I've
been on my own spiritual journey and and
coming back to a lot of these things and
it's like for as crazy as you might you
might say any of these stories are that
Moses parted the Red Sea or that Jonah
lived in a whale or any of these things
it's like well it's not that crazy
considering that uh you know the
Department of Education thinks that guy
with a penis is a woman so and you know
as a as a Storyteller I read the Bible I
I do not read the Bible literally in
every way you know I mean I think that
there are stories in the Bible there are
legends there are myths there are all
kinds of ways of communicating the truth
because the truth is so complex and so
deep that you can't just say one thing
and the people who say that everything
has to be taken literally to haven't
read the Bible because the Bible says
that's not true the Bible says that the
letter kills but the spirit gives life
I'm not dismissing everything in the
Bible as metaphor or myth or poetry I'm
simply saying there are moments when
you're dealing with different genres
because it takes every genre to tell a
truth that deep and to be honest you
know if you read the first three or four
chapters of Genesis and you don't see
The Human Condition plumbed to its
depths you're not reading it right
because that's the most profound piece
of writing on Earth really and I think
that when you read the Bible right it
explains so much and and not just about
the world but about your own life it's
an amazing amazing book I got one more
for you because as I was reading the uh
synopsis The the last line here I'm
going to just read a portion of it uh
he's they're talking about Cameron
winter he can't resist the chance to
apply this deductive power in the
pursuit of justice for the victims and I
read the and I read the whole thing and
I thought man the word justice has been
so mucked up lately you're talking about
justice of victims that have been killed
rightly so providing them justice but
the word justice because of social
justice I think when people hear the
word Justice now they mean something
very very different well I'm not the
first person to say that the left has a
habit of taking perfectly uh definitive
words putting a modifier in front of
them that means no so if you have
Justice what does Justice Means it means
people get what they deserve that's what
Justice Means you know so the murderer
get something very different than the
decent man than the saint they're going
to get a different thing but when you
put social justice in front of it when
you call it social justice that means no
justice it means that people are not
getting the Justice they deserve and we
see that in our cities when you know
rapists are set free and rape again and
then people uh kill killers in
self-defense and they're prosecuted so
we see that happening right now but the
thing is what what Cameron winter
doesn't want is he doesn't want things
to to to not make sense making sense is
one of the most profound things you can
do with life when you say something that
doesn't make sense like oh yeah these
people who are raping and murdering and
beheading babies these are the good guys
when you say that a little bell should
go off in your head and say well wait a
minute I got to go back somewhere along
the line in my logic progression I made
a mistake and so that's what Cameron
winter does he's not a professional
detective he's a guy who sometimes reads
a story in the news and thinks wait a
minute that explanation doesn't make
sense and he goes in to find the real
the real story and that to me is a very
powerful thing even when only one person
does it the book is the house of Love
and Death and Andrew as a man who has
converted once my continued quest to get
you to convert from whiskey to tequila
is still it's still out there man deep
for me that's not religion that's too
deep I'm
sorry it was good to see you my friend
we're goingon to link to the book right
down below thanks a lot Dave good to see
you if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop screaming
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell